Science asks big challenging questions about
the nature of the universe.
Answering these questions often requires collaboration
across scientific disciplines and national
borders.
But what happens when countries are isolated,
at war, or just don’t get along… what
do scientists do then?
In some areas of science it’s impossible
to do research without collaborating with
another country.
The United Nations Educational, Scientific,
and Cultural Organization (or UNESCO) reported
that in 2015 an average of 1 in 4 published
scientific papers listed some form of collaboration
with foreign scientists, and that number continues
to grow.
For instance, the high altitude, lack of atmosphere
and dry conditions in certain parts of Chile
make it one of the best places on EARTH to
view activity in outer space.
This is one reason that it is estimated by
2020, 70% of the global infrastructure for
astronomical observation will be located in
Chile.
With the rest of the world’s astronomers
dependent on their facilities for sensitive
measurements good relations are critical if
research in astronomy is to advance.
But consider what happens if countries have
a challenging political relationship.
US relations with Cuba for instance have been
famously strained since the 1960’s.
While exchange of scientific information was
never expressly forbidden, US embargos on
everything from travel to trade between the
two countries has made it difficult for Cuban
scientists to access instrumentation and equipment
that scientists outside the country take for
granted.
This is because modern reagents and scientific
equipment are often manufactured in, or contain
parts, from the United States which exempts
them from sale to Cuba.
Even with these challenges, Cuba is a superstar
of science.
They were the first country to receive validation
from the World Health Organization for eliminating
mother-to-child transmission of HIV, and their
lung cancer vaccine was an early success for
cancer immunotherapy.
These innovations made formalized scientific
collaboration between the US and Cuba politically
more attractive and in 2014 the American Association
for the Advancement of Science and the Cuban
Academy of Sciences signed a historic agreement
to “seek opportunities for sustained cooperation.”
In order for them to fulfill that promise,
the two countries had to agree to work together
outside of the laboratory, and this newfound
scientific relationship coincided with a general
easing restrictions between the US and Cuba,
including a relaxation of travel restrictions
and a historic visit to Havana by President
Obama himself.
But of course, 2016 feels like a long time
ago, and the current US administration doesn’t
have the same approach to collaboration.
So it remains to be seen if these agreements
are allowed to continue.
Where the public may perceive hostility, scientific
collaboration still continues… because scientists
find greater value in, well, science.
In other parts of the world, international
collaborations like the Human Genome Project
and the particle accelerator SESAME in the
Middle East (which includes unfriendly countries
like Iran, Pakistan, and Israel) are pushing
humanity’s knowledge of the universe forward
and creating havens of cooperation in a time
of increasing nationalism.
When it comes to highly visible, international
“moon shot” projects like CERN’s Large
Hadron Collider or the International Space
Station-- a project reliant on cooperation
between Russia, the United States and others
-- the whole world is watching.
The sheer scale of investment puts these massive
collaborations in a delicate diplomatic position
that can make them critical points of de-escalation
and compromise in otherwise gridlocked negotiations.
They can also inspire us to acknowledge that
we’re all just bunch of humans stuck on
a rock racing around the sun at 67,000 mph
(108K km/h).
And in the words of Louis Pasteur: “Science
knows no country, because knowledge belongs
to humanity, and is the torch which illuminates
the world.”
As another example, we’re working on a deep
space gateway with Russia, go here to learn
more and don’t forget to subscribe for more
science in your day!
Did you know that during the cold war, The
US and USSR were working together for science?
When the Soviet Union's Cosmos 936 mission
launched in 1977, seven U.S. biological experiments
were onboard.